- Welcome back, everybody.
Our next guest has blown
my mind once already
on our show.
He's been described by
"The New York Times"
as having the effervescent wit
of a good dinner party host
and the cunning of a master jewel thief,
which is a really good description.
His hit off Broadway show is called
"Asi Wind's Inner Circle".
Let's say hi to Asi Wind again, everybody.
(crowd cheering)
(soft music)
What's going on?
- Keeping busy.
- I am very excited you're here.
You know I love magic.
I'm very excited.
How's your show going?
- It's going great.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I mean, we started the show.
We thought we were gonna
do a couple of months
and leave and pack, and
we extended six times.
We've done 370 shows to date.
(crowd cheering)
- That's cause you're so awesome.
It's cause you're so good.
So what are you showing us today?
- We're going to try something,
it's something to warm up,
and then the main course, all right?
- [Kelly] Okay, oh, I like it.
- Okay, all right.
Let's stand, and I'll ask everybody here
to think of a two digit number
of the last passcode of
your phone, let's say.
Everybody think of it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And if you already have a number,
raise your hand.
Quick, quick, raise your
hand, raise your hand.
All right, how about you
with the beautiful jewelry.
It's a watch, I think.
Do you have a two digit
in mind of your last?
Don't say it, think it, okay.
- Got it.
- [Asi] You did that?
- Yep.
- Great.
All right, I, before the show started,
I wrote the number on this board.
- No, you didn't.
- Yeah, yeah, you'll see, it's crazy.
Okay.
- You don't know him, right?
- I do not know him, never met him.
- No, no, okay, okay, ready?
- For the first time,
say the number out loud.
- Two, one.
- Also known as 21.
(audience laughing)
- Valid.
- We almost had the same
number, that is crazy.
- Did you really think it?
- Should I tell you the first two?
- No, no, no.
Okay, you ready?
- Yeah.
- Do you wanna see it first?
- I just want everybody to see it.
There's no way you have a two and a one.
Well.
- Exactly.
(crowd clapping)
- It's there somewhere.
- Right, correct, right.
Okay, okay, it's buried in there.
So, when I wrote this, I
used two types of markers.
One is permanent, and one is dry erase.
So for example, if you did
this, it will erase, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- If you did here, you wanna try?
Try that to 95, try this.
- [Kelly] Okay, let me try.
- Yeah, or every one of them will erase,
but one number is permanent.
You said 21, right?
- Yes.
- No way.
- [Asi] Try to erase 21.
- Yeah.
This one was mine, 22.
- No, no, I wrote 21 really big.
Look, I'll show you what I mean.
If I erase everything, but everything.
- [Kelly] No!
(audience gasping)
- This is 21.
(audience clapping)
So, thank you.
- You've never met?
- Never met him before.
- What the hell?
- This is the appetizer.
Let's, let's do something crazy, shall we?
- That was crazy.
- Thank you.
All right, let's do something crazy.
- Okay.
- Crazier, so this is 100 numbers.
We're taking it up a knot,
1,000 pieces of a jigsaw puzzle.
Now here's the deal,
every person here would say,
oh maybe they're all the same.
You're here to verify
that they're different.
- They are different, yes.
- [Asi] So grab, mix them
up a bit if you want.
- [Kelly] Okay, those are different.
- And then pick about five
or so, like this much.
Not too many.
- Okay, just like that.
- Go ahead, like about five, six pieces.
Yeah, put 'em here, put them
right in the center here.
And turn them all facing up.
- [Kelly] Oh up, okay.
- So we can see them.
And you're the eyes,
also we'll zoom on it.
But you'll see, even
these that are very close,
they're different.
Even that, different.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Even the shape, every one of those.
Can you divide them into two groups?
Three and three, any way you want.
Any three.
- [Kelly] Boo, boo, boo, boo.
- Okay, which three, either
three, it doesn't matter.
- [Kelly] These three.
- [Asi] These, can I take these?
- [Kelly] Sure.
- All right, so every
choice you make is your own.
I'm not trying to influence your choice.
- I know.
- From these three, look,
one, two, and three.
Can you pick any two, any two of them?
It's up to you.
Any two, and put 'em right,
yeah, put them in the bag.
That's perfect.
- I'm so nervous, okay.
(audience laughing)
- Don't worry.
- Okay, okay.
- Is it fair?
From 1,000, you chose six, then three.
You said, get rid of the other three.
Then I asked you to remove two.
- Yeah.
- We're down to one.
- Yes.
- I knew you were going
to choose this one.
- [Kelly] Why?
- I'll explain.
I have the exact same puzzle at home.
All night, it was a lot of, I
put all the pieces together.
- Yeah.
- And I, I didn't have time to finish it.
I was missing one piece.
- No.
- Yeah, yeah, it's right here.
- You are BSing me right now.
(audience laughing)
- It's an image, and
it's missing one piece.
- How in the world would you
know from me randomly grabbing?
This is not a part of the show.
I'm not a part of this.
You are totally, I wanna remove it.
- It's up to you.
- Can I look at it?
- Let's do it together, ready?
- Okay.
- Let's just take it off.
There's one image here.
- Okay.
(audience awing)
- No!
Oh my gosh!
(audience laughing and clapping)
That's my dog!
I just got it.
This is my dog, Henry.
Aw, this is my Henry.
- It's a gift for you.
- Oh my gosh, you, I need
to know how you did that.
You are, this is why it
keeps getting extended.
I'm so hot right now.
Oh my God, I'm burning up.
Okay, give it up for Asi Wind, everybody.
(audience clapping and cheering)
That is incredible.
Be sure to check out
"Asi Wind's Inner Circle"
at New York's Judson Theater
now through January 14th.
We will be right back.